[Music]
Lego Star Wars yay finally you guys have
been begging me to play this for weeks
and weeks and weeks so here we are it's
actually my chest favorite game but I
just want to get this done okay I mean I
love this game and we're gonna play now
I'm just no I know it's no I was I was
setting it up yeah we're playing it
together
[Music]
yeah you look so good today
[Music]
my future you know I'm quite gone hello
there I know qui gong gym I didn't think
Lego Star Wars is so hard
[Music]
okay all right you don't edit my video
he tells you okay wait what else is Brad
tell you I'm taller than you I don't
know yeah Oster destroyers
must destroy tell me I love it why you
like this game know what I love there it
is not a story okay because I don't
really know much about let's test how
many minute Orient's we have okay Oh
general Kenobi wait was it general
Kenobi yeah
why is he a general is that in that I
was joking I was Joe Reddy's off no I
was joking I'm watching them right now
okay I saw them
I can't believe it have podracing now
this is podracing that's another one how
do we progress in this game can we
trying how do we please this is YouTube
okay if you're gonna call ahead with me
[Music]
you might say you are the most beautiful
girl in the whole know people wanted us
to play Star Wars and this is just us an
e-book to progress how the kids figure
out how to get in how do you do it how
did you do it how did you do it I use
the pool okay do we just hit resume you
quit wasn't me no it wasn't no hey I'm
sorry what did you do
oh my CI I just got the car I can't do
it Oh a surprise to be sure but a
welcome one
a surprise to be sure but a welcome one
by the way my said you are strong and
white and I'm very proud of you you are
strong and wise Anakin and I am very
proud of oh you are on this council but
we do not grant you the rank of Master
what
I don't like sand it's coarse rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere not
like here here everything is soft
and smooth okay I can do that what is
the matter
Phoenix don't like sand it scores it's
Rob it's their routine then it gets
everywhere but not like here
notlikethis better acting then the freak
will explain me thank you so much Marcia
for joining me on another adventure this
will be the first episode of the whole
thing so if we if you felt like we
didn't progress
don't worry more is coming or it's
coming
what did I say the communications a
disruption in the communications can
mean only one thing
invasion how does that relate a
communications disruption can mean only
one thing
invasion you didn't like Star Wars you
didn't like this video right but what
you should do is smack like how long
have you been doing this
five hundred thousand likes and will do
part to check out Marcia's channel and
leave a link in the description and as
always like the full spin
[Music]
[Music]